part two of my college administration
was after me for selling these t-shirts
so after the lady couldn't get us in
trouble for the trademark issue or using
her college name she informed us that
the college was getting complaints about
the back of the t-shirt and then she
told us that we were promoting sexual
assault
with a t-shirt now this is the back of
the t-shirt so you can decide for
yourself but i'd like to say that we
clearly put an ore black out or back out
anyway so we didn't want to get in
trouble so we just left the bonfire and
ended up going to the dorms to sell the
rest of the t-shirt but mind you we had
350 t-shirts so this was a small school
so they were all over campus so then i
find out from my volleyball coach that
the administration is asking all of the
coaches who was selling the t-shirt and
the funniest part was my coaches had
bought a t-shirt from me the t-shirts
were sold out at that point so they
never found us but if you're in college
and want to make a chunk of change i do
recommend making t-shirts like this